françois qui a prêché si les gouvernants
moi je salue votre courage d'être venu
malgré tout milieu de la mêlée comme ça
aujourd'hui c'était pas gagné
maintenant je pense que quand même avec
les mots poule vous dites que vous
n'êtes pas plu pendant trois mois
mais c'est une chose de prévenir pendant
trois mois c'est une autre chose quand
il ya une agression économies parce que
toute une agression économiques ont
suivi directement les ou en poule avec
tous les sacrifices qu'ils ont faits
c'est une autre chose quand une
agression économique qui est fait comme
ça
et y'a pas un mot qui a pas communiqué
lâché par votre mouvement en marche et
que vous n'avez pas pris une seule fois
la parole sur ce thème là pas forcément
non sur un site mais dans aucun débat
télévisé nulle part et donc j'ai là je
pense qu'il ya un abandon tous les états
unis je vous le redis je pense que
l'ambiance que vous avez ici vous payez
le fait d'avoir été absent pas seulement
ne pas être mesure dont je vais sauver
le site
mais de pas avoir pris plus de chez vous
maintenant il ya un mot avec lequel moi
je suis pas d'accord c'est quand vous
parlez de nos entreprises délinquantes
malheureusement ou whirlpool n'est pas
une entreprise d'un accord ça serait
bien que ça soit un dysfonctionnement de
l'économie
c'est son fonctionnement ordinaire c'est
son fonctionnement c'était son
fonctionnement chez goodyear on est allé
chercher du coût du travail moins cher
cette échéance ou fonctionnement chez
continental ou là les syndicalistes
avaient été gentil il avait accepté tous
les sacrifices et néanmoins c'est parti
en roumanie
ça a été le cas chez parisot siège de
france ou de la même manière on est
parti en roumanie il ya eu zéro plan
social pour les salariés à la cantine
donc c'est le fonctionnement ordinaire
de l'économie vous connaissez déjà
fettig
ma question c'est comment vous allez
allez remettre du bras d'un bras de fer
avec le patron de boue et le pdg de
whirlpool aux états unis qui se paie
aujourd'hui 13,5 millions d'euros
c'est à dire autant que les 290 salariés
de whirlpool n'a cinquantaine de
salariés de climat et les 100
intérimaires qui interviennent sur le
site
comment vous allez faire pour que demain
n'est pas 10% dividende
versez en plus aux actionnaires de
goulottes cool en ans confirme le site
d'amiens c'est ça la question
c'est la question qui a été posée deux
fois aujourd'hui
donc une fois par la terre ça décale ce
matin jeudi c'est la même question qui a
été posée par l'intersyndicale plus
palerme monsieur macro et tueur pose la
même question
donc en fait ça reste une question
importante pour nous parce que on dit la
pince elle se porte pas bien mais ça lui
prend quelle france je suis désolé
monsieur macro mais pas de france vous
venez de recevoir le soutien de bernard
arnault l'homme le plus riche de france
est mon ami personnel comme vous le
savez bien fait la même chose
le pdg de lvmh a invité ses entreprises
à délocaliser en l'occurrence était en
pologne puis c'est parti en bulgarie
parce que le fonctionnement l'union
enfin le parlement
et c'est pas des matchs tu es pasion
mediacorp si c'est donc au pied qu'elle
plus aux filiales dans les paradis
fiscaux
donc je sais pas qu'est ce que vous
allez faire quoi aussi pour lutter
contre bernard années le poste
finalement est pareil fiscaux mais là on
n'est pas dans l'orne du
dysfonctionnement de l'économie c'est ça
que les salariés doivent mais
malheureusement dans l'ordre de son
fonctionnement ordinaire
et si jamais bien moyen pour les patrons
et les actionnaires de gratter de
dividendes supplémentaires en allant
chercher du coût du travail moins cher
ailleurs
eh bien ils le furent au et là moi dans
tout ce que vous avez dit vous savez là
vous êtes au milieu des vaincus la
mondialisation vous pouvez pas venir
leur dire que la mondialisation et que
l'européanisation les bonnes alors que
ici dans le point on s'est pris des
coups depuis 30 ans se prend les coups
dans la tronche ça a commencé par le
textile c'est la métallurgie
malheureusement les gens que vous allez
me tenir debout dans leur famille ils
peuvent tous citer plusieurs plans
sociaux d'affilée et bien plus
[Applaudissements]
la mondialisation c'est quelque chose de
positif
ben non ça peut pas être ressenti comme
ça ici et moi je peux pas vous mentir ça
c'est vrai quand vous dites que moi je
suis désolé une part de fermeture et
frontière ça veut pas dire qu on a chaud
entre l'autarcie et et et le libre
échange
mais oui une part de fermeture des
frontières ça me paraît pas forcément
être négatif nouveau genre vient la
question centrale 10% de dividendes en
plus pour les acteurs quelle france
parce que vous dites la france se porte
pas bien
désolé je pense qu'il se porte très bien
dividende record pour le cac 40 cette
année 56 milliards d'euros et grâce à
vous en partie puisque vous avez
augmenter les marges avec le très bien
beaucoup positivité emploi donc voilà il
ya eu france qui se porte très bien et
là vous êtes au milieu d'une fort
penses-tu ce corps complètement mois 4
et 8
même le basket huit nations j'ai fait
quelques arrêts et à la seconde non non
c'est la batterie
malheureusement cette occasion j'ai
finir comme ça pour ses pantalons coupés
interdire de verser des dividendes ou
interdire à une entreprise de fermer un
site qu'elle a décidé de fermer
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
possible et qu'il n'est pas possible et
qu'il serait même contre-productif
pourquoi parce que il ya une liberté
d'entreprendre et il ya une livre
programme a été dans notre nom mais n'en
a d'ailleurs jamais donné leur disons
que vous dites vous n'avez jamais
entendu ni je finis je réponds à votre
point donc là dessus je ne porterai pas
cette réponse parce que c'est pas vrai
si je fais ça demain y'a plus personne
qui viendra investir en france parce que
diront le jour où il ya un problème
c'est un pays on n'a pas le droit de
fermer une structure c'est un pays où il
n'ya pas de oui oui il n'y a pas la
possibilité de le faire au regard plein
d'investissement pardon de vous le dire
mais l'amazone on en parlait il s'est
installé
[Musique]
non non il y aura tous les âges
s'il vous plaît tous les âges havrais a
condamné la vraie écoute
gt gt jusqu'à la semaine dernière
j'étais la semaine dernière dans le 78 g
gries ils ont réembauché l'année
dernière je suis tombé sur deux salariés
c'était des femmes de plus de 50 ans qui
avait été embauché parce qu'ils ont
investi une dose yann l'on vient mais
dont nombre de questions mais juste en
qui je viens de faire moi un petit point
amazon vous dit
amazon va faire re créer des emplois
mais c'est un exemple vous savez qui
s'étire tout d'abord un brouillage de
dire et je sais maintenant ce que lance
jacques et vous savez ce qu'il nous a
dit avant de partir les accusations donc
donc à partir de là
n'allez pas dire qu'ils vont venir nous
employés savent déjà tout s'est fait en
trois étapes le mans le projet que je
porte c'est la grande différence avec
tous ceux qui ont gouverné jusqu alors
c'est un plan de formation de 15
milliards pour tous les âges pour
investir dans les gens qui sont
justement qui tombe au chômage aux et
court aider à ces reconversions parce
qu'on en a besoin parce que c'est pas
vrai qu'on arrivera à maintenir tout au
long de la vie les emplois une liste
complète est pas vous raconter trahir
votre boulot mais non mais il y en a du
boulot mais les différentes voix de
velours il y en a
mais non en même temps on cherche 285
donc voulu le dire est qu on en cherche
que deux en quatre ans
évidemment qu'à des zones ont levé les
yeux mais on a besoin d'entreprises qui
viendraient investir
on a besoin de requalifier et on a
besoin de recréer et peut-être en
pologne que moi aulas qui avait envahi
nourrit donc tu pas de problème là
dessus non plus en train de vous dire
c'est que dalle pse ya la reprise ya la
reprise du site et derrière il ya en
effet la formation la formation qui
n'est pas eu le don de la pluie de
perlimpinpin parce qu'il faut pouvoir
retrouver les nouveaux emplois donc non
je n'interdis ray pas aux entreprises de
fermer des sites à fleurir par contre
est-ce que vous comment les rues dans sa
requête de manière concrète sur le cadre
et aux poules
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on si on peut
faire des choses c'est qu'on peut pas
continuer à avoir un fort chômage et il
vend en france qui achètent cap une
heure sur huit qui se comporte comme ça
avec le bilan qu'a donc c'est une vraie
politique de dénonciation est donc là je
vais leur mettre la pression mais moi je
ne veux plus derrière compte distribuer
qu'on achète et qu'on incite à l'achat
de machines de l'entreprise qui a décidé
de le faire c'est du cas par cas et je
ne ferai pas une loi qui l'interdît j'ai
pas vous raconter des craques parce que
je n'y crois pas parce que je pense que
c'est pas efficace non plus au micro par
contre mais non mais donc je vais pas
vous le dire aux pauvres mais par contre
ce qui est sûr c'est que on peut en
ayant un vrai rapport de force
clermont temps les chercheurs avant de
partir vous donnera un tract que notre
ça a déjà été donné au coeur de la
ramasser les crottes heures j'ai les
crocs de quoi tu n'as pas eu lui mais il
distribuait hier mais il vaut le coup de
lui transmettre
donc voilà pour montrer à quel nom alors
je veux dire ça s'est produit
oui mais comme ça ne peut pas faire une
taxe uniquement sur vos produits et je
ne fais pas de taxe sur tous les
produits importés pourquoi pas se faire
plein de produits qu'on ne produit plus
en france on ya 10000 mais qui
s'inquiète paul on achète rapport sur la
question posée crise de la diminuer
arrivée à l'om c'est fini vous pouvez
très bien vers le choix de taxer
spécifiquement le sèche linge par
exemple n'en relève tout ce que je peux
faire c'est décidé d'avoir une vraie
bras de fer avec leur poule et en effet
cédé 6 d'aller au bout qui se comporte
pas bien sûr ps la reprise donc
d'annuler le non c'est ça qui est bouclé
leur série camelot pas les ramener la
pollution d'un ras-le-bol
ce serait une promesse en l'air